POLICIES.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
>>> AFTER HIS LAME ATTEMPT TO
ANSWER HIS CRITICS, JOE BIDEN
SPENT THE REST OF THE TIME ON
THE VIEW DISCUSSING THE CAMPAIGN
OF HIS CAMPAIGN LAUNCH VIDEO,
THE CHARLOTTESVILLE EVENTS IN
2017.
>> I WROTE AN ARTICLE AT THE
TIME IN "THE ATLANTIC" MAGAZINE
WHEN CHARLOTTESVILLE HAPPENED.
THIS IS SNOT WHAT WE ARE.
IT'S ABOUT DECENCY, HONOR,
INCLUDING EVERYONE.
IN LEAVING NO ONE BEHIND.
I DON'T REMEMBER THAT HAPPENING
IN AN ADMINISTRATION BEFORE IN
WELL OVER 100 YEARS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING TO
RELITIGATE ALL OF THIS.
WHAT THEY SEE IS A TROUBLING
MOMENT FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TODAY THEY PRESSED HIM ON HIS
WAY TO THE NRA CONVENTION.
WATCH.
>> YOU LOOK AT WHAT I SAID, YOU
WILL SEE THAT THAT QUESTION WAS
ANSWERED PERFECTLY.
AND I WAS TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT WENT BECAUSE THEY FELT VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THE MONUMENT TO
ROBERT E. LEE, A GREAT GENERAL,
WILL YOU LIKE IT OR NOT.
>> HERE TO REACT IS
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
TURNING POINT USA AND PRESIDENT
OF DEMOCRATS FOR EDUCATION
REFORM.
LADIES, GENTLEMAN.
IS THIS A LEGITIMATE CAMPAIGN
OPENER FOR BIDEN?
AND YOUR REACTION TO THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS THERE.
I'LL START WITH YOU, SHAFFAR.
>> THE CHARLOTTESVILLE ISSUE
SPOKE TO THE CHARACTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE SAID THERE WAS BLAME TO GO ON
BOTH SIDES.
WE HAD WHITE NATIONALISTS AND
WHITE SUPREMACISTS WHO CAUSED A
DEATH TO A PERSON.
RACE HAS BEEN A FAULTLINE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND WE NEED A PRESIDENT
TO BRING THIS COUNTRY TOGETHER,
NOT TEAR IT APART.
>> CANDACE YOUR TAKE ON THAT.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED WHITE
SUPREMACIST FINE PEOPLE.
IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT HAPPENED.
HE SPECIFICALLY SAID I AM NOT
SPEAKING ABOUT WHITE
SUPREMACISTS OR NAZIS.
AND WHAT'S REALLY BIZARRE IS
THAT JOE BIDEN OF ALL PEOPLE
WOULD USE THIS AS A WAY TO
LAUNCH HIS CAMPAIGN.
HE IS A MAN WHO WAS MENTORED BY
ROBERT BYRD, A LITERAL KKK
MENTOR.
HE HAS ISSUES WITH BLACK AMERICA
AND I'M REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL AISLE HAVE SPOKEN UP
AND POINTED OUT HIS HYPOCRISIES.
>> CNN'S VAN JONES THINKS THAT
BIDEN PLANTED A PERFECTLY LAID
TRAP FOR THE PRESIDENT.
WATCH.
>> HE'S GOT HIM RIGHT WHERE HE
WANTS HIM ALREADY.
BUT REALLY, IT'S SO PAINFUL TO
HEAR THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SIT UP HERE AND BRAG ON A
TRAITOR, BRAG ON SOMEONE
CREATING AN ACT OF TREASON.
IT'S PAINFUL.
IT'S WRONG.
WRONG-HEADED.
BENEATH HIM, BENEATH THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
BUT FROM A POLITICAL POINT OF
VIEW, JOE BIDEN SHOWED THE WORLD
HE KNOWS HOW TO PUT A BANANA
PEEL IN FRONT OF THE PRESIDENT
AND WATCH HIM FALL.
>> HAS BIDEN LAID A BANANA PEEL
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO FALL ON?
>> NO.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE CANDIDATE
THAT IS GOING TO BEAT PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP AND THAT IS THE
TRUTH.
THEY HAVE NOTHING THAT IS NEW.
TO ME JOE BIDEN IS THE NEW
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY'RE GOING TO CELEBRATE HIM
AND SAY HE'S HIGHLY FAVORED WHEN
IN FACT HE IS NOT AT ALL.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT HE DOES
NOT HAVE ANY POLICIES.
HE'S DOING MORE FEAR MONGERING
AND BEING HYPOCRITICAL AND
AMERICA IS NOT GOING TO FALL FOR
IT.
WE'RE DOING MUCH BETTER UNDER
THIS PRESIDENT THAN WE WERE
UNDER OBAMA.
>> IS THIS REALLY WHAT THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS
LOOKING FOR IN A CANDIDATE, SORT
OF IDENTITY POLL
OF IDENTITY POLITICS, THIS GUY
IS A RACIST AND I'M NOT,
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM FROM
TRUMP.
WHAT ARE AFRICAN-AMERICANS
REALLY LOOKING FOR IN YOUR
OPINION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE
UNEMPLOYMENT TRENDS WE SEE TODAY
STARTED WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE BUSH
RECESSION, THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WAS 17%.
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA LEFT OFFICE
8.5%.
ORBED THE BUSH RECESSION, THE
LATINO UNEMPLOYMENT RATE REACHED
13%, LESS THAN 6% UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
WE'VE SEEN IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS UNDER TRUMP
BUT MOST OF THE TRENDS STARTED
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DISMANTLED
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHICH
AFFECTS WORKING FAMILIES ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY, DISPROPORTIONATELY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND THAT SORT OF CHARACTER, THAT
RACIALIZED CHARACTER IS WHAT
WE'VE SEEN FROM THIS PRESIDENT
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME?
WHAT ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
I WANT BOTH.
YOU TO REACT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
WE HEARD IT TALKED ABOUT DURING
HIS ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS NEVER ENACTED.
NOTHING WAS DONE.
CANDACE?
>> WOULD SAY THIS.
BLACK AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF
BEING UNDERMINED.
THAT'S BEST EVIDENCE THAT
DESPITE THE RHETORIC, DESPITE
THE MEDIA TRYING TO LABEL TRUMP
AS A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
WE'RE TIRED OF PEOPLE ISSUING AN
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE TO DONALD
TRUMP.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO OFFER POLICY
TO FIX OUR COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S ONLY TRUMP
OFFERING POLICIES.
I PREDICTED OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP
IS GOING TO BE THE PERSON THAT
CRACKS THE BLACK VOTE BECAUSE
WE'RE TIRED, FATIGUED WITH THE
RACIAL ARGUMENT.
>> YOU DO SEE NUMBERS IN SUPPORT
FROM AFRICAN-AMERICANS RISING
FOR TRUMP.
TO WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I'M NOT
OFFERING EMOTION, I'M OFFERING
FACTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST THIS YEAR
SOUGHT TO CUT $200 BILLION FROM
THE STUDENT LOAN PACT, 200.
>> STUDENT LOANS AFFECT
EVERYBODY, HISPANICS, WHITES,
CHINESE.
>> THEY DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> THE MAJORITY OF BLACKS DON'T
MAKE IT TO COLLEGE SO THAT'S
DISHONEST.
>> I GOT TEN SECONDS LEFT.
>> I MEAN I WOULD LIKE TO
FINISH.
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> JUST CORRECTING YOU.
I'M SORRY.
>> I'M GOING TO CORRECT YOU NOW.
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA WE SAW
RECORD NUMBERS OF BLACK PEOPLE
COMPLETE COLLEGE.
>> RECORDS ARE NOT THE MAJORITY.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THAT
ATTEND COLLEGE ARE WHITE.
I WANT TO CORRECT THE RECORD.
>> DRAMATICALLY THERE ARE MORE
WHITE PEOPLE IN COUNTRY.
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
WENT UP.
>> THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT
STUDENT LOANS AND WHO THOLED
WOULD IMPACT.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
FINISH.
AGAIN WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
ELECTED, THE AFTERA MATH OF THE
WORST DEPRESSION,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES BEFORE DOWN 50%, LATINO
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES WENT DOWN 50%
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> HISTORIC LOWS NOW.
I GAVE YOU PLENTY OF TIME.
YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING MY
QUESTION.
WHY ARE BLACK AMERICANS NOW
RISING IN THEIR SUPPORT OF
DONALD TRUMP?
YOU GOT FIVE SECONDS.
>> WELL THEY CAN GO NOWHERE BUT
UP.
HE WAS CLOSE TO ZERO IN BETWEEN
SO THEY MAY GO UP INCREMENTALLY
BUT HE'S GOING TO LOSE THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND LATINO
VOTE.
>> NO HE'S NOT.
I'LL ANSWER IN FIVE SECONDS.
BLACK PEOPLE AREN'T STUPID AND
WE'RE GETTING TIRED OF THE RACE